there was a whole big dinner of my guys
planned with uh blit JD Chris Wilding
and others Jason they were all going out
for some fancy duck dinner there was a
big fight between JD and Chris and they
were sitting now at opposite ends of the
table they couldn't even and now their
friendship is over what's going on there
Jason what can you tell us I thought we
were having a great night we're out
drinking at a very fancy place and
restaurant and drinks and drugs and all
sorts of fun festivities laughter and
then I I left the table to go outside to
uh have a smoke uh I come back upstairs
very happy and the entire mood has
changed and I can only imagine being
high and then JD goes you go hey JD what
happened between you and Chris and he
goes I see so he said and he said to me
and I said to
him does that what it sounds like you
there JD why don't you we're all
straight now why not you explain to us
what happened between you and Chris with
without Chris interrupting well I was uh
I was a little we were both a little
drunk and I don't know how it came
up and I shouldn't have said anything in
the first place I should just let it go
whatever but for whatever reason I
thought I was able to um Express
something that uh that I've been feeling
and but you know not exactly I'm not big
into confrontation and stuff I thought
we could sort of do it in some like
jokingly way or something I don't know
so uh I don't again I don't know how it
came up but we're talking and he's like
you anything
yet I'm like oh yeah shut up shut up is
this pretty much the explanation you got
no no hold on hold on hold on right so I
said to him you know I you know it kind
of annoys me that you do an impression
of me like almost during every meeting
uh you know you know something like that
and uh he sort of you know got you know
a little offended or whatever goes oh
what about this person what about that
person they they doing an oppression of
you too you know and I go well they
don't do it as much as you do he goes
that's not true that's not true at all
I'm understanding what you're saying and
I will say this to Chris JD is a really
good sport the JD impression Howard can
I can I just stop you for a second
because I really don't want to I'm
really not looking to do like you know a
team Chris team JD whatever I'm just I'm
not e he's not going there I haven't
said anything yet I love Chris I love
you I'm just trying to give I'm going to
give Chris A New Perspective here's the
thing JD is a real good sport he is and
you can tease him a little bit about you
know and all that kind of stuff it's so
much fun to do the JD impression I
understand what CHR and it's an easy
laugh everybody loves it but like
sometimes we'll be in a meeting and JD
will just go I have an idea and everyone
goes like he gets out with like like a
lot of people just going and like well
JD has some good stuff to say but I
think he he just says to himself I'm
going to keep quiet so everyone doesn't
jump on my back right he's being stifled
what do you think I think he overreacted
Chris I wasn't there but um do you think
what I'm saying has some
legitimacy ye there is what's strange
about this is you know listen in June JD
and I were on the air literally kissing
each other yeah back in Miami we were
holding hands on a plane you know JD and
I have had on air and off air tiffs in
the seven or eight years I've worked
here something has happened in the last
month and a half I believe certain
parties are in JD's head about me and I
think when I then go no this is true
something is happening behind the scenes
there's been a smear campaign I know as
far back as Miami there were people
going around to mutual friends of mine
like a JD saying don't hang out with
Chris Wilding don't hang out John blit
they're going to ruin your credibility
at this organization it's a smear
campaign
[Music]
who J there anybody putting a thought in
your head so this was the second this is
sort of what led into this he you know
he he goes I know I know what's going on
I know what's going on and then he says
this and then that sort of offended me a
little bit because it's like oh well now
now I can't have a a thought of my own J
J no it's not it's not
where are you guys at right now let I'm
out of the JD business I will not make
any more jokes about JD I will not say
his voice I'm not putting up jokes
anywhere about him I don't if if I've
done something to offend him and there's
a sensitivity with me he doesn't have to
worry about that anymore I'm out of the
JD business wow that's big uh JD what do
you think about Chris being out of the
JD business he's blocked me on Twitter
he's uh unfriending Instagram I didn't
block you on Twitter absolutely not I
don't Chris I go to your profile and
you're I'll show you right now I didn't
block you buddy what just that no listen
I spoke to to Jason we were at we were
at
dinner maybe I did I
spoke well I'll unblock you that was too
far but I spoke to Jason no no I don't
want to block you I spoke to Jason about
two weeks ago we were at dinner we were
at a pizza place and I said is there am
I crazy or is there something about me
that makes people irrationally kind of
nuts and crazy
Jason said yeah man there there's
something there so I just feel things
are going on behind the scenes and I
think it's getting into JD's head he
knows that he hears me do his voice in
the meeting and he goes you know what
you're right that guy is a son of a
he said yeah sometimes I can't
help myself I got to you know do
whatever I can't either I I I I try to
limit my JD impression uh but sometimes
I can't help my I do a Richard Christie
voice I do a John blit voice I mean I do
a voice for everybody especially in the
morning meeting that's kind of what I'm
there and I do so I just find it odd
that all of a sudden JD is like really
really turned against me JD are you
friends with Chris that's all I want to
know uh right now I I just I I work with
him I wouldn't say we're friends see
Howard this was the the most
uncomfortable hurtful part of the dinner
and it really did hurt me even more so
than the Ralph stuff there were two
other guys at the dinner who were trying
to calm things down and they said JD
let's get past this really you do like
Chris you're friends with Chris right
he would not say he liked me or was my
friend and that that must been a great
dinner and those poor ducks that died
while you guys ate them I that's what I
feel duck was great the duck was worth
the drama so he lik the duck like me it
didn't ruin it for you this well we had
the duck and then after this was after
we the duck JD this is not like you man
something has changed something CH board
now that's enough of your fight okay
that's it I'm done I've never seen
someone eat more duck than JD in my
entire life
that's enough I'm telling you something
there were two platters of duck enough
for six people this guy went from one
platter to the other to the other one
he's dark me the skin he was he was
hoiston sauce cucumbers the the pancakes
I mean I've never seen I don't even know
was there a problem that JD was hoarding
most of the duck for himself did not
have enough he growled at people when
they tried to take a piece but I was
like JD relax there enough duck for
everyone to go around and we can order
more so it's a beautiful meal though a
beautiful
meal